trauergottesdienst im zug am ersten
oktober 2001 14 kerzen brennen für 14
kantons und regierungsrat
sie alle wurden opfer eines attentats
wurden grausamsten der schweizer
kriminalgeschichte
begangen hatte es friedrich leibacher
mit seiner tat schockierte er die ganze
schweiz und veränderte das leben von
vielen lange zieht wenn ich ihn zum ich
bin eine trank war wie in syrien hinter
mir so dass klappern statur test hat das
ist für mich so ein kann als sie und
erinnert an ein schuss der fall von
friedrich leibacher hat in vieler
hinsicht als umdenken bewirkt es geht um
sicherheit vor der behörde
parlamentsgebäude gerichtssaal
aber es gab auch fracht also wie muss
man wasser kontrollieren und es gab eine
frage was macht man mit personen
psychisch auffällig sind
[Musik]
der tag der alles veränderte der 27
september 2001 die explosion im
regierungsgebäude
wir sind dann sofort der hannovers und
jedes gebäude und sehr stur auf hof
verhandelt sie mit zwei große tasten
sind nicht aussprach bluetooth sind mit
mit blutspuren den sind daher steht an
kritisch sagen wir kommen auch die ewig
kurz gut präpariert die opfer mit mit
blut sie andauernd nicht aussprach baut
sie aber so wie sie mir in meinem text
steht das ist verwirrt die situation sie
im stadthaus sein der lytro hand hilft
und lütow stark oder abo sind darauf den
starken gast sind und schauen sich das
eindrücklich sie führen aber doch nicht
dass man froh ist man doch gemerkt dass
306 nicht unüblich das ist realität
diese realität war so unfassbar dass die
betroffenen nicht wussten wie ihnen
geschah will dir auch die möbel erik
medhus gegen die logik dahinter und die
krone kanton verdienen und trifft in
deckung und ich bin ab sofort unsere
tisch denn blut kann ich für mich der
herr komisch dass der schule schlechter
arbeitet haben doch gar nicht die
jahreszeit der dax einmal ruhig sie und
dann schieße und denn sie immer einfach
drunter bleiben bewegt mich nicht
erinnere sich da mit ganz viel übt am
boden 100 gleiche wie ich es nie
verstanden wieso um ihren boden erlitt
ich bin aufgestanden
die avantgarde rund um fenster
feinstruktur 3 mio und das erst mal
realisiert wahrscheinlich dem ruhm in
abgeholt und liegt direkt am tv wo das
paar meter vor mir steht zum glück der
rocker mehr zu erklärt hat natürlich gut
erinnere standen polizei und der
tätigkeit am frisch latex und ich kann
eine motorische diensttelefon kino oder
auf der aktionsseite polizei aufbieten
und und für mich und sanität
sie geht aber vor allem wurde also was
gesagt sie hätte sie blüht weiß nicht
habe ich noch mal kurz zum fenster
zugewendet haben wir über leitungen sie
springen aber sehr viel mit steinplatten
ich habe mich dann entschieden
getrocknet und dann hat aber leichte
körperverletzungen mit dem strahl schuss
oder andere decken wie bei verletzung
und vor der bereich und das intenso die
zehntelsekunde waren
das leben hat er mir auf das label oder
abgegangen ist nicht merkt es ist jetzt
ein punkt kann ich muskuläre welt hat
kann ich mir im partners leben immer
küste strömen im final die sache mehr so
ganz wenige sekunden
der kopf gegangen sind und er weiß
natürlich einfach wartet bis es mich
trifft
und deshalb konnte ich dass sie mit dem
ganz außergewöhnliche aktivität und arzt
und und deutschland frage also ob sie
sich als ruhiger wurde vielleicht schon
voraus dass wiederwahl und schaffen im
roxy und produkt davon betroffen monika
seifert eine sanitäterin accell group
gestorben
innert zwei minuten und 34 sekunden
erschoss der attentäter 14 menschen und
verletzte 18 weitere zum teil schweren
danach richtete sich friedrich leibacher
selbst
ich glaube das ist also eine geschichte
forum wo sich immer mehr soziopathische
verhalten hat und wo immer mehr
querulatorische ich lager gegenüber den
behörden europa hat und da haben die
einfach normal reagieren hat sogar
versucht den kompromiss mit ihm zu
finden man hat ihn durchaus ernster aber
er hat einfach mit seiner klagen auto
chance kam friedrich leibacher war im
zug kein unbekannter der 57-jährige war
immer wieder bei den behörden vorstellig
geworden meistens um sich zu beschweren
die letzten gespräche fanden am telefon
statt
es hängt zwischen ihm und mir ungefähr 5
telefon sprach stattgefunden
die solidarität und freizeit was für
rechtliche möglichkeit erhält einen
konflikt mit dem der schiffe von der
verlesung der namen oder im vorverfahren
angetrunkenen zustand ohne der chauffeur
de zugerland verkehrsbetriebe und
friedrich leibacher lagen zu diesem
zeitpunkt bereits drei jahre lang
miteinander im streit
begonnen hatte das drama am 17 oktober
1998 im restaurant burg in bar bei einem
wirtshaus streit legte sich friedrich
leibacher mit dem chauffeur an und
bedrohte ihn mit einer pistole
schon damals war laibacher als querulant
bekannt
ein vorwurf der zu einer ganzen reihe
von anzeigen führte ausgangspunkt ist es
auch für laibach wackelt raúl gericht
bedroht wurden die beiden hand hofbauer
und wird so street car muss auch der
vorwurf sie vom harry potter star tom
cruise mit dem bus fahren sie aus dem
user hat sich dann ein regelrechtes
lacht entwickelt vom leib auch glatteis
affäre hatte mehrfach gezeigt wegen
verschiedener delikte aus um schließlich
ist es gibt einen sie viel
rechtsstreitigkeit zwischenzeit habe und
um hereinbrachen
ärztliche gutachten entlastete den
buschauffeur das aber verstärkte laibach
aus überzeugung dass er es mit einer
verschwörung zu tun hatte deshalb klagte
er fast alle an die mit dem verfahren
etwas zu tun hatten auch die
vize-präsidentin des kantonsgerichts die
den ihr verletzungs prozess zwischen dem
buschauffeur und laibacher behandelte wo
allianz missbrauch begonnen dome wo
staatliche korruption der 100 briefe ab
prozess vom regierungsrat besiegte inkin
bezirkslisten steuerzahler oder so hätte
er immer argumentiert und sogar no hay
intensiv zur sorge steigere das mittel
hexenprozess der gebühren in seinem
frust und seiner empörung wandte sich
friedrich leibacher an die medien
er schrieb einen leserbrief den er in
der zuger zeitung veröffentlicht sehen
wollte
der lask nicht publiziert die geschäfte
publiziert wir sind es auch wieder
gegangen nachdem viele noten
recherchiert hat und hat der bitte
bezüglich roh sind ja das ist jetzt viel
was er behauptet dass das klarstellt
dass sheen dreht
schließlich suchte er auch den kontakt
mit dem kanton
er schilderte dem land schreiber seinen
missmut über die zugerland
verkehrsbetriebe und die
untersuchungsbehörden das letzte dieser
gespräche fand etwa zehn tage vor dem
attentat stadt telefon erlaubt aus
juristisch überraschend gut versiert aus
entschlossen entschied korrekt fordernd
und frauen drohen transit ins gefühl
kommt es zu einer einigung
die telefongespräche forum sprachlich
ausgegangen dass er natürlich andere
antwort von mir erwartet hat und von der
einigung autotelefon sprach hält man
nicht reden er einfach de durch das
bedürfnis mit über offen und ohne
zeitdruck über die probleme reden
aber friedrich leibacher konnte sich
weder mit dem kanton noch mit den
zugerland verkehrsbetriebe nase
für mich kommt einfach immer die drei
begriffe absolut rechthaberische mensch
also wenn wenn ich mich einfach zu
bedienen oder selbst sprach wenn ich ihn
versuch das lecke was mehr interne
munter nur hand was die untersuchung
resultat sind dann interessiert das
eigentlich nicht will eintracht mit dem
was er geschrieben andere interessiert
ihn nicht dass ich so einfach komplett
rechthaberisch und wenn immer niedrig
gibt denn ich das ja erwähnt
friedrich leibacher hatte einen
schwierigen charakter
zu diesem schluss kommt auch ein
psychiatrisches gutachten das über 180
seiten umfasst drei wochen hatte eine
ausgesprochen auffällige persönlichkeit
wir würden das als eine sogenannte
persönlichkeitsstörung bezeichnete der
erste problembereich ist eine
pathologische egozentrik das bedeutet
dass bedürfnisse und wünsche der eigenen
person völlig über alles andere gestellt
werden das was ich wünsche das was ich
fühle ist der maßstab aller dinge und
der maßstab für die bewertung aller
phänomene zweiter problembereich
großartiges selbstbild also die
überzeugung besonders wichtig zu sein
besondere fähigkeiten zu haben und
deswegen eine besondere bedeutung zu
besitzen
dritter problembereich einigen puls
steuerungs defizit das bedeutet dass
impulse schlecht gefiltert werden
sondern eins zu eins ausgelebt aus
agiert werden vierter bereich
zwanghaftigkeit das heißt
dass menschen die zwanghaft sind sind
auf details fixiert auf kleinigkeiten
dazu kam ein erhöhtes angstempfinden
sowie wut und hass psychisch auffällig
war friedrich leibacher schon als kind
er wuchs zwar einzug in sogenannt
behüteten verhältnissen auf doch geriet
ja schon früh mit autoritäten in
conflict das geht aus mehreren
psychiatrischen gutachten hervor die in
seiner kindheit gemacht wurden
der explorer wurde am 21 juli 1944 in
zug geboren
der explorer hat sich schon früh als ein
schwieriges kind gezeigt über das die
eltern bald die autorität verloren
bis zur fünften klasse ging hier zur
schule
der in der region ev sie als kind
aggressiv dass er seine crew sporne etwa
beherrschen und dass er wenn man nicht
im qualität also dass er tore fixiert
er war als unverbesserlicher care
bekannt als er als 13 jähriger wegen
einer schießerei in eine
strafuntersuchung hineingezogen wurde
und nach einer auseinandersetzung mit
seiner mutter einen wutanfall bekam
wurde er hierbei tätlich und erklärte
ihr sie die mutter müsse ihr billiges
leben hergeben er gebe keine ruhe bis er
ihr blut sehen
friedrich wurde mit 13 jahren
vorübergehend in die strafanstalt zug
gesteckt später kam er mit dem
einverständnis der eltern ins
katholische st georgs heim in bad claude
will dort sagte ein gutachter über den
16 jährigen
ich betrachte fritz leibacher als nicht
ungefährlichen psychopathen im einzelnen
bietet fritz das bild eines haltlosen
auf bequemen genuss eingestellten
anpassungs schwierigen bedenklich
gefühlskalten krankhaft
überempfindlichen an einem schwer
geschädigten selbstwertgefühl leidenden
raffiniert berechnenden im ganzen gehabe
unechten der projektion seiner fehler
verhafteten zu hochstaplerin getue
disponierten sexuell verdächtigen
jugendlichen der sich zuletzt und zu
tiefst nach einem gemütlichen zuhause
sind
aufs ganze gesehen muss freezers
verwahrloster innerlich total ins
ordnete für kriminelles tun disponierte
psychopath beurteilt werden die
[Musik]
prognosen schienen nicht eben günstig
im katholischen st georgs heimgesuchte
friedrich leibacher die sekundarschule
es herrschten enge verhältnisse und die
proben wurden streng erzogen hier lernte
laibacher seinen besten freund kennen
mit dem er ein leben lang in kontakt
blieb der kannte ihn von einer ganz
anderen seite als die gutachter sogar
sechs wochen im paket also in den händen
gemacht oder friedrich leibacher war
nicht leicht zu fassen
das zeigte sich auch bei dieser gruppe
von psychiatern und psychologen unter
der leitung von frank urbaniok versuchen
sie im auftrag von ämtern und behörden
das gefahrenpotenzial von möglichen
tätern einzuschätzen
umso verbrechen zu verhindern zur probe
zwecken analysierten sie jahre nach dem
attentat auch das täterprofil von
friedrich leibacher ohne dass sie
wussten um wen es sich handelte brisant
ist dass dabei ein großteil der experten
die gefährlichkeit von laibacher falsch
beurteilte und sein gefahrenpotenzial
verharmloste ich würde sagen es etwas
damit zu tun dass ein neues meister war
im verbergen im täuschen manipulieren
und sehr geschickt auch formuliert hat
und wusste wo bewegt er sich in einen
strafrechtlichen bereich hinein wo nicht
er hat ja auch diese juristische teil
ausbildung gehabt und von daher fühle
ich dass er darauf zurück dass ein teil
der gruppe zu wenig hinter die kulissen
sprich auf die persönlichkeit geschaut
hat die dahinter steht mit der langen
vorgeschichte die es auch da gibt
seither ist bei den gutachtern eine
solch gravierende fehleinschätzung nicht
mehr vorgekommen
das wäre auch fatal denn schließlich
sollen sie verbrechen attentate oder
amokläufe verhindern
eine absolute sicherheit bieten die
einschätzungen aber nicht vor allem dann
nicht wenn sie kurzfristig erstellt
werden
also muss sage im rahmen von
strafverfahren weil es unseriös
gutachter abstützen muss die person
persönlich untersuchen
nur so haben die psychische störung
genau und bdp name und und einsprachen
maßnahmen schaffen
also das ist ganz wichtig dass das da
person genau erklärt wird
es ist nur in notsituationen wo man die
spitze wie es in einer familie
konfliktsituation hat wo man ebenfalls
telefonisch befragt aufgrund der
aktenlage größere gefahr besteht beim
gefahrenpotenzial und der persönlichkeit
von friedrich leibacher gingen die
meinungen auseinander
das hängt vermutlich auch damit zusammen
dass er sich von verschiedenen seiten zu
zeigen musste
[Musik]
hier in seelisberg wo laibacher bis zum
frühling 2001 wohnte war er als
umgänglicher typ bekannt
im restaurant bahnhof war er ein
beliebter gast erklärte regelmäßig ein
trank zwei drei gläser und hatte immer
einen spruch auf den lippen
wenn man mitmacht
das ist ganz anders könnten die mieter
seines chalets ständig belästigte er das
paar und verlangte zutritt zum haus
[Musik]
später überhäufte friedrich leibacher
die künstlers und das mit gericht mit
klagen und beschwerden sowie später die
behörden in zug und beschwerden führen
konnte er denn nach der matura an dieser
zürcher privatschule studierte er jura
das studium schloss er zwar nicht ab
doch es kam ihm bei seinen schreiben
zugute
er kannte ich trainiere kriegs die
grundzüge sich gewandtheit die im umgang
mit wörtern mit juristische wörtern hand
bieten verschiedene gesetz gefunden
das bringt das augustiner schriebe er
ist im umgang mit wort
auch sonst war er schlauer
immer hatte er schicke autos und geld
das verdiente er sich unter anderem mit
dem verkauf von einträgen in
branchenbüchern die aber nie erschienen
er war ein kleinkrimineller und hatte
schon damals verschiedene verfahren am
hals
[Musik]
auch solche wegen exhibitionismus im
wald bei bremgarten zeigte sich
friedrich leibacher mit offenen hosen
einer jungen frau auch am türlersee und
in hausen wurde er so gesehen
wegen dieser vergehen wurde er
verurteilt
er musste zwei jahre in die
arbeitserziehungsanstalt später kaufte
er sich eine yacht mit ihr segelte er
1985 über den atlantik und ließ sie
schließlich auf der dominikanischen
republik wieder hier verhielt er sich
soweit ruhig er arbeitete zeitweise als
unternehmensberater und kam mit dem
gesetz nicht in konflikt
auf dem schweizer konsulat kannte man
ihn zwar aber aus anderen gründen
[Musik]
vorliegend zu viel stand vorfall
behandelt
tatsächlich hatte friedrich leibacher
hier drei mal geheiratet und zwar
innerhalb von nur vier jahren aber alle
frauen verließen ihn zwei davon waren
erst 16 jahre alt aus den verbindungen
gingen drei kinder hervor
er konnte ganz ruhig mit einem reden und
plötzlich schickte er einen zum teufel
er wurde wütend ohne dass man etwas
macht dass es sich aber zu einem
attentäter entwickeln würde konnte
damals niemand ahnen
ganz klar dass mit screens kennt man so
ganz
e mail
das ist ein großes buch stellt das leute
zu mir die verschiedenen gesichter von
friedrich leibacher ziehen sich wie ein
roter faden durch seine biografie
generell haben alle menschen die
möglichkeit in unterschiedlichen
lebenssituationen unterschiedliche
facetten ihrer persönlichkeit zu zeigen
das machen wir alle in gewissem ausmaß
bei fröhlich laibach ist es so dass es
ein mensch ist der durchaus über soziale
kompetenz verfügt der kann gesellig sein
der kann auch lustig sein
er hat die fähigkeit im
zwischenmenschlichen kontakt die gehen
aber nur dann oder diese nur dann
realisierbar wenn es nicht irgendwelchen
anderen interessen widerspricht diesen
konflikt gibt wenn der dinge durchsetzen
will dann sehen wir eine ganz andere
seite und das ist eine dominierende
seite in der persönlichkeit von
friedrich lama haben um bei einer person
die dominierenden aspekte und die risiko
disposition einzuschätzen wurde von
frank urbaniok fortress entwickelt diese
systematische analyse dient der prognose
des gefahrenpotenzials dabei wird die
persönlichkeit minutiös aufgesplittet
zusammen mit der entsprechenden
biografie erhalten die experten so ein
persönlichkeitsprofil einfach gesagt
wenn wir die person gut kennen und die
lebensgeschichte kennen und in der tat
musste analysen machen und wir haben
diese beiden quellen
dann kann man sehr zuverlässig
gefährlichkeit einschätzungen vornehmen
das geht aber nur wenn alle akten
zugänglich sind
bei friedrich leibacher war das nicht
der fall
die unterlagen über seine vielfältigen
vergehen waren über verschiedene kantone
verstreut
das war mit ein grund weshalb er
ungehindert zu waffen kam ohne dass
jemand hellhörig wurde
man muss unterscheiden zwischen erwerb
war früheren und hühner ist es relativ
leicht sie der waffe zur werbe
insbesondere wenn man das privat kraft
hat da hat es überhaupt aussätzige käse
ist nicht irgendwo im waffengesetz
gregor xi
der frieden hat also schon mal baywa
verkauft aber hat im handel waffen
erworben und tätig sie dass man unter
anderem ein privates strafregisterauszug
moresby bringen
jetzt war staaten sollen private
strafregisterauszug drin da stand drin
weil die verurteilungen der
vergangenheit galt die person vorgänger
sind jetzt hat aber im alten system eine
möglichkeit um die trackpads lösche und
zwar nach gewisser fristen ist das
anspruch katers das gelöscht wird das
heißt also man hat zwar grösster ist
irgendwann mal verurteilt wurde aber
größer ist dass sie dem
strafregisterauszug immer sichtbar sie
mit seiner strafregisterauszüge und
angela verhandlungen und hat sich wieder
verkauft
ganz so einfach könnte sich friedrich
leibacher heute nach der revision des
waffenrechts keine waffen mehr besorgen
bei der tat hatte er ein ganzes
waffenarsenal und einen brandsatz dabei
bekleidet war er in eine selbst
gefertigte uniform mit der aufschrift
polizei
dazu trug eine baseball mütze mit
aufgesticktem zuckerwatte so ausgerüstet
stürmte er am 27 september 2001 den
zuger kantonsrat sal
[Musik]
innert zweieinhalb minuten feuerte er
rund 90 schüsse ab und zündete einen
brandsatz
der zufall entschied wer überlebte und
er nicht
[Musik]
vor der tat schrieb friedrich leibacher
ein pamphlet tag des zornes nannte er es
er fühlte sich von den behörden völlig
unverstanden sicher fraglich dass das
man sprechen müsse haben um personen
oder irgendwo in alles wo ihn ernst
nimmt und das spricht eher für seine
institutionen über wir einen umbau
stellen
wo personen wo das gefühl hat sie wertet
vor der behörde nicht richtig behandelt
oder im gang mit dass die irgendeinen
ansprechpartner hand ob man dadurch
sondern da kaum verhindert das ist
natürlich schwer zu sagen
aufgrund des attentats hat der kanton
zug 2003 eine ombudsstelle eingerichtet
der sogenannte vermittler in
konfliktsituationen behandelt im jahr
gut 100 fälle von unzufriedenheit mit
der betreibungsamt bis hin zu problemen
mit der zuger polizei
bisher konnte der vermittler in
konfliktsituationen die strittigen
punkte zwischen behörden und bevölkerung
klären und so eine weitere eskalation
verhindern
damit es nie mehr zu einem attentat
kommt wurden zudem die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen verstärkt
im bundeshaus und in den
kantonsparlamenten überprüfen seither
röntgenapparate schleusen und detektoren
die besucher so soll die sicherheit der
parlamentarier gewährleistet werden auch
in zug wurden solche
sicherheitsvorkehrungen installiert und
zusätzlich eine außentreppe angebaut was
ich dir einzig bauliche maßnahmen vor
ort
dort war es wäre sinnvoll umbau er sich
das so genannte fluchttreppe oder
nottreppe das problem nach dem attentat
ich sehe das locker andere
fluchtmöglichkeit kloster die einzig
euro blockiert sich nichts mehr erinnert
heute an der schreckliche szenario vom
27 september 2001 der saal samt
bestuhlung wurde renoviert
einzig vor dem regierungsgebäude sorgt
ein mahnmal dafür dass das was damals
geschah nie vergessen geht eine tat die
auch deshalb geschehen konnte weil
niemand die explosive verknüpfung von
friedrich leibacher handeln und seine
psyche erkannte wenn man erkrankte die
dass er seine waffe akkumuliert und zur
vorbereitung trifft dann ist es ja
eigentlich eher schwierige frage ist das
schon im strafbaren bereich und da ist
mir dann mit des strafraums behördliche
es gibt nur zweite schiene das wäre
rechtlich fürsorgerischen
freiheitsentzug griff dann wenn opa für
uns stehen die oder für sich selber
akute gefahr bedeutet dann dürfen wir
ihnen wiesen in eine psychiatrie und
innere freiheit den zuwachs in villa im
strafrechtlichen bereich wenn es um
schwere delikte sind
vorbereitungshandlungen strafbar und
dann darf man ihn in untersuchungshaft
also wenn das schon so weit gediehen ist
vorher ist es strafrecht eigentlich
machtlos will als bruch der immer
strafbar zum können intervenieren
bei laibacher hatte niemand interveniert
auch dann nicht als seine erste ex frau
in die schweiz kam und darauf hinwies
dass mit friedrich etwas
stimmt das war im sommer 2001 ich dachte
eines tages wird er sich töten oder
etwas verrücktes machen
ich habe allen gesagt friedrich brauche
hilfe
auch der polizei in zürich aber niemand
hat auch nicht gehört zum zeitpunkt des
attentats war seine mutter die damals
hier in bar wohnte 85 jahre alt
die tat ihres sohnes hatte auch sie
erschüttert in einem brief an den
regierungs und kantonsrat sowie an die
angehörigen schrieb sie im november
danach ich hatte geglaubt meine zu
kennen
nach allem was ich erfahren habe musste
ich erkennen dass ich mich getäuscht
habe und weiter das leben jeder mutter
ist mit dem leben des kindes eng
verbunden
deshalb trägt mein herz mit an der
großen schuld die er auf sich geladen
hat
mögen ihre namen so verheilen dass sie
nicht ein leben lang leiden müssen
in stiller trauer jeder geht mit dem
attentat anders um
[Applaus]
rösler kommt immer wieder auf diesem
friedhof um für herbert arnett und die
anderen 13 opfer zu beten
auch 2009 nach knapp acht jahren
beeinflusst die tat sein leben
[Musik]
ich danke sich der heimlich abschluss so
wickelt das setup schließe ich lebe
heute bewusster irgendwie gehört dass
ich im hausgang um mich von meinem
partner verabschieden auch wenn man dann
auch weniger schöne immer diskussion man
kennt das thema genuss und dass man
bereinigt die stimme kennt mittlerweile
zeigt er doch dass sie auch andere
bezugspersonen hält dass sie nicht bloß
gilt dann als bezugspersonen sind immer
wieder denkt wer weiß was man isst was
immer stunde ist dirigent ihrem leben
auch ohne orientieren und die eltern
vermutlich hätte sich das attentat von
zug nicht verhindern lassen ob sich in
anbetracht eingerichteten
sicherheitsmaßnahmen heute eine solche
tat verhindern lässt bleibt ungewiss
denn die absolute sicherheit die gibt es
nicht
[Musik]